c'est une image figée dans le temps
quatre militaires russes autour de leurs
polikarpov coucou conçu pour le travail
agricole puis transformé en avion de
combat par les alliés c'est surtout l'un
des nombreux trésors conservés qu'on
peut apercevoir au musée ou mmc de wirth
naya pich ma pour célébrer la défaite
nazie de 1945
le musée rétro situé à quelques
kilomètres d'ekaterinburg expose en
effet une trentaine d'aéronefs comme
celui ci le 9 mai où la veille beaucoup
de gens veulent ressentir l'importance
de la victoire
ils veulent montrer à leurs enfants le
prix de cette victoire présentait avec
l'aide de la technologie et de nausées
les mondes expositions et à sochaux
bien sûr le 9 mai c'est la dette la plus
significative pour ouvrir de 1939 à 1945
près de 800000 aéronefs ont été produits
par les deux camps ici bombardier avions
de chasse ou cargo autant allemand
qu'allié sont présentés sur les onze
mille mètres carrés ouverts pour
l'occasion d'adhérer au principe
d'équivalence historique
nous montrons des avions soviétiques de
la zone des hâtifs
c'est à dire que les américains et des
britanniques et nous accordons également
une certaine attention aux avions
allemands
si les détecteurs hautaine ils verront
le chasseur allemand faute bulls et le
meilleur schmitt bf 109
nous essayons de tout l'entrée l'une des
nombreuses merveilles de cette
exposition
le catalina offert par les américains
aux russes surnommé le bateau volant cet
aéronef pouvait amerrir naviguer et même
redécollé sur l'eau les visiteurs sont
fascinés l'idée géniale en fait de
montrer ces machines ce qu'elle était
avant
c'est intéressant pour les générations
suivantes pour nos enfants
nous avons la chance de vivre dans
l'oural de vivre si près d'une telle
opportunité
il est très rare que vous puissiez voir
de telles machines les voir vivante à
côté de vous quand vous impressionnent
par leur taille
et comme il ya toujours un homme
derrière la machine l'exposition rend
aussi hommage à grégory reds call of
pilote de chasse et héros de guerre
soviétiques
créditée de 56 victoires en combat
aérien on estime que le conflit a fait
entre 40 et 60 millions de morts
avec 21 millions de pertes civiles et
militaires
l'urss a payé le plus lourd tribut parmi
les belligérants